only one that was good was the ninja
turtles ninja turtles
that is a special place in my heart
cowabunga dude
cowboy dude
[Music]
have any of you guys came across a story
about
this florida sheriff who has
defended the revelation
of his past where he when he was 14
years old he killed a man
oh [ __ ] in self-defense yeah and now
people that
are like what the [ __ ] cuz he's a he's
an elected official right because he's
he's actually like the county sheriff
he's the sheriff yeah and so now people
are like
why the [ __ ] didn't you tell us you
killed someone when you were 14.
it's hard to lead a speech with that
[Laughter]
yeah why would they yeah because like in
their eyes
is like well you're you're like supposed
to protect the community but you did
something so heinous in the past and you
didn't but he's been a sheriff for like
more than
14 years of his life like self-defense
and it was self-defense he didn't go to
jail for it what the [ __ ]
so it ended up happening back in 1993
when he was 14 years old there was this
local
drug dealer guy who was harassing him
and his brother
and so this 18 year old drug dealer
ended up chasing him and his brother
because he pulled out a gun
and then he chased him and his brother
into his house and that's when
tony the sheriff pulled out his father's
handgun
and shot the drug dealer several times
in self-defense so
because of that reason he was exonerated
the
juvenile courts were sealed and he
never ever got charged with anything
right so because of that reason it never
like popped up in any
like background checks and stuff but
somehow this came to light and didn't
you want a badass sheriff like that
that's right when i was a kid i [ __ ]
did this and afterwards i was like
there's too many criminals in the world
i got to do something about it and then
he became sheriff man yeah i've been
fighting crime
since 14 years old how about you [ __ ]
also at an age where that could
traumatize you you don't want to bring
that up
and it's like part of your past exactly
and then like
i'm with you joe because when i read the
story i was like why would
that is a sheriff you would have won
yeah what's the other argument i think
it's the transparency
aspect is that well if you're gonna
elect someone that has the capabilities
of shooting someone then we want to know
but
then but then you go back to the idea of
like you're a [ __ ] cop i expect you
to shoot
yeah it's a [ __ ] weird backlash
the backlash is also like it's grown a
little more
because of the fact that tony has
doubled down and said like
i don't need to disclose this with you
at all like this was from [ __ ] 27
years ago
or however long and i it was
self-defense i don't need to
go into the details of this entire case
with
with you like the public right yeah
there are statutes of limitations so
if it's 27 years it's a long [ __ ] but
if he's becoming a uh
he's running for like a public office
position he's already
here he's the head of like he's the
sheriff he's the sheriff
oh just got elected just recently
announced so that is a public
position exactly so that's why people
feel entitled to know what happened and
then even
like the the lawyer came out and
like his attorney he said that he
doesn't have the files
technically but it's a bad pr move it's
i mean he doesn't have to
literally tell anybody but as a
sheriff i think it might be your public
duty to talk about it
i don't think so because i feel like at
that stage people are also dumb where
they're like if you did talk about they
will start looking at you different way
yeah you know it's like it's how long
ago was it 27 years 27 but it's a sign
of leadership and strength i think
a publicity move but it's been so long
that you wouldn't even think about
bringing it up you know yeah
no no but even if you don't even
remember just lie that's what a great
politician does
right they create a good [ __ ] story
and then they
like i just i'm a better politician than
this [ __ ] because i wouldn't run
away from it i'll be like i was 14 years
old
i got chased by this drug dealer i
didn't know what to do i was scared
and then i said my daddy taught me how
to shoot and i said
well it's me either me or him and i had
to save my brother
boom killed that [ __ ] and then i
was prepared to go to jail i went to the
cops
and then i realized this is what i want
to do for the rest of my life
so you vote for me cause i'll protect
you and i'll shoot those drug dealers
down
bam [ __ ] vote me and that's what
i'll do
there's a lot of great and what you just
said and that's for sure and i'm not too
sure of like the
aristocratic uh in the florida right
south or aristocratic south is like
i don't know what this is all the states
i believe uh
uh the state where trayvon uh mr trayvon
got shot and
uh you know is the state where people
would back that kind of behavior maybe
he doesn't want to use the fact that he
killed someone
as a right political move that's true
he's like why can't we talk about how i
[ __ ]
that's exactly what he said how i did a
[ __ ] bake sale he was like why can't
we talk about the last
27 years of professionalism yeah what
are the things on his resume
what about that food drive i did you
guys don't want to talk about that yeah
maybe it even affects him in a negative
way whether or not he
defended himself right maybe he's like i
don't want to talk about the fact that
as a teenager i had to kill a person
yeah but i taste my cinnamon rolls
during the bakes hell it was [ __ ]
good
it's like say someone that had uh was uh
like a politician or someone that was
elected was raped as a kid
uh and they put that behind them would
they also have to disclose that
information
when they run i guess because he's not
committing a crime
it would be different if he could have
made a crime he didn't commit a crime
either because he didn't commit a crime
yeah
like it was himself he wasn't charged in
self-defense it's something that he's
unquestionable crime yeah like
but if he was a victim that's true he
was a victim of having to shoot somebody
for
for being yeah and especially at that
young of an age like it's not
something that like we also forgive at
like up to a certain point depending on
what you do and that's part of your past
um plus he was completely like the
victim if the story like is true
and it's also like the timing part is
hard because if he goes okay i want to
run for sheriff
when do i tell them yeah do i tell them
now okay or maybe should i wait until
i'm about to get elected
and after you get elected you're like by
the way yeah you killed someone let's
get
almost like no good time because what
you could say is oh he's a trigger happy
chef he might do that to a
that's exactly the people's argument he
was 14 years old
also as a sheriff you're not out there
just being like hello public
yeah you know what [ __ ] curly
mustache
i feel like all the people that do judge
him they should pull up
what they did when they're [ __ ] 14
years old and see if they still want to
be branded
must throw the first stone kind of thing
or in dave chappelle's words he
without stan will throw the first rock
and he will smoke it
but also what he did was good it's not
nothing that he did was bad
so this is gregory tony the sheriff
and i'm racist because i i pictured a
complete redneck with a hunter's
uh shirt um so uh
i apologize for my thoughts you didn't
have to tell us yeah
and he was also wearing an orange
hunter's vest just all the time
no i didn't picture blackmail was he
wearing the the freaking the hat too
and everything no more fud hat yeah that
one i forgot his name
no no no he had a he had a cop's haircut
you know like a buzz cut
yeah yeah and a mustache was it curly no
no no it wasn't it wasn't like that it
wasn't no
no it was like a cop stash yeah cop
stash a picture of elmer fudd and the
the cemetery what what's that yo
somebody sam yosemite that guy a picture
of that like merged
well now that it's out in the open are
people finally calming down like it's
he's talking about it now yeah what are
the apps are people like i would have
taken my vote back if
if i would have known there's people
that are like that because like
and also you know with the elections and
all that like the next time he gets
elected or whatever
there's people that are like well i
won't vote for him in the next time
because he shot somebody when he was 14.
well because he
didn't disclose that to the pole you
think this is a race thing now that you
brought up the whole race and i'm like
[ __ ] like
do you think it was like imagine like
yeah the sheriff is black
and when he was 14 he had a gun a youth
black youth with a gun shots and shot
and killed someone
might have been white yeah but if this
person was white do you think the public
i think it would have been worse if he
was white i think i don't know i think
with the cops and everything with
having a white cop that shot someone
they would be like oh he could go around
and shoot like a
uh a black person him being black
surprised me in terms of how they're
still
going after that if that didn't erase
surprised me it actually
made more sense because for me i'm
thinking about it in community right
right
and in a white community in florida
republican i'm assuming right that
they're more
pro-gun and they would like a sheriff
that
uh fights crime like with a gun right
versus
uh stereotypically minority communities
are more
anti-gun so when they heard this they're
probably like what the [ __ ]
what kind of sheriff are you and so when
he when i saw that he was a minority
it made more sense than than than a
white sheriff that's why i pictured
a white cop yeah and who's leading the
charge is it the
other guy who lost the election he's
tattletail he wants to keep pointing
this out that's not transparent he's not
transparent
that makes sense well the governor did
mention
that most like the residents have been
mostly positive and they've and then
pointed out that voters will be able to
to speak with their vote in the next
election but
there are just certain people that are
like what the [ __ ] and how do the cubans
feel because
we only said white and black but there's
a huge cuban population
so i'm like who's he the sheriff of what
kind of community
it's a broad county
i have no idea words downwards is that
miami
to left or right orlando that sounds
like where miami is
jacksonville just from the sound of the
name sounds like it is
i could have sworn i saw in bad boys or
something
it's one of those things it's miami
right i don't know no dave dade county
wade dwyane wade miami heat dade county
god dammit okay yeah yeah it's fort
lauderdale hollywood
boca raton i don't know my florida
statistics but he's been a good cop for
20 something years
i don't know how long he's been a cop
but that's almost like that's a long
time
there's a statute of limitations if you
fart
and didn't announce it and it's been a
long time
if you didn't announce it then it's like
yeah after 30 minutes you're gonna talk
about it yeah you don't gotta talk about
it
but you should have announced it when it
happened okay but like okay
i'm sure in his 27 years especially how
long he's been a cop to move up to being
a sheriff
he's probably talked about it how many
times is he's gonna have to talk about
it no because he's actually they
mentioned like
he just never so he says no one ever
knew about it he didn't see the need to
disclose that 1993 killing to the
governor or
on other applications during his law
enforcement career because he was a
juvenile
and he was cleared yeah well yeah they
do ask you a felony but
he didn't commit a felony so he didn't
have to yes where did he put it on the
forum
ps i killed a man once but i wasn't
convicted
yeah like where do you put it that's
true so it's like it probably
he wouldn't have gotten a job based off
that record you know makes sense which
he proved himself to be
moving up in the ranks here i mean
that's the point of going to court right
so and having a record and all that [ __ ]
so if you don't have a record
why should you still be brand new right
with a as a criminal when you when
you're not
considered one yeah it's so weird that
like okay the you go to court
so they can tell you if you're guilty
you're innocent right they told him he's
innocent
so he's an innocent man but now it's
like you have to
what the public is saying is as an
innocent man you have to also carry
around this story
that could have that could make you
potentially put you in a guilty
perspective of some sort it's weird
i was almost guilty but i wasn't yeah
just let you know
and i farted so shut up try my cinnamon
rolls
[Music]
you